[Music]
in sniffing silence news submitted by
ghetto superstar loved that song a salon
offers a silent haircut option to
customers to give a break from our
overstimulated world ooh that's nice I
would like to request this at times you
don't have any hair baby no no I don't
even taking this a burn anymore I'm
invincible I'm invincible
it's a really short break from you're a
survivor thank you thank you I'm a
survivor no so when I go get my hair cut
and yes it's very fast yeah sometimes
they do talk to you and I'm just you
just want to chill yeah it's worse for
like yeah even if you did have hair your
haircuts like how long but like for like
I have to go to the hair salon for like
five hours no I don't take that whole
[ __ ] you know what a real pain we're
painting I don't want to doing I do like
when they massage your hair then tea
tree oil do that to you oh yeah you know
do this for you know you get your hair
washed
no yeah wash but not with teacher lip
this or so whatever is in that shampoo
it's like this like mentholated like
your scalps like like i do get scalp spa
like scalp facials things I used to I
used to go once a month but then I got
to crazy is way too attended a scalp
facial yeah it's like part of your
facial I'm not sure melted in the chair
I'm like please don't let this ever end
yeah it was so good anyway so this salon
called nut not enough hair salon another
not another salon in London is offering
a new service to its customers who don't
feel like having a chat with their cuts
and so they're saying that you can
request the silent haircut it's now an
option for whenever you booked an
appointment and it will be no extra cost
to clients so this is the photo that do
posted on their Instagram why would it
cost more I know but I guess just in
case people were wondering it's like
just think you know it's not a yeah yeah
and then so the caption is here and it
says the world's first silent haircut
were known for includes inclusivity and
our no judgement policy but now we are
taking it one step further by becoming
the world's first salon to officially
offer a service when booking to opt out
of general chitchat
well many while so many of us love a
chinwag at the hairdresser's others I
know my British or anything yeah that's
in London um just need wait what
hairdressers others need some time out
and that way let me start that sentence
again cuz it threw me off while so many
of us love a chinwag at the
hairdresser's others just need some time
out and that should be okay to ask for
so why is it we feel embarrassed to say
we need some quiet time why do we feel
we need to bury our heads in a book and
hope they get the hints is is it that we
are too British to ask your stylist will
still talk to you through your through
your consultation and any hair related
information throughout your service but
the rest of the time is yours all you
have to do is ask for a silent cut or
color when booking and no one will judge
you for it in fact the stylist would
probably also love it - not another
salon will always be a loud and hectic
environment full of Chat Chat er and
laughter but we feel we can cater to
everyone more than ever before
I think I just want to hear them talk
first before I decide yeah interesting
you just tell me about yourself real
quick and then she's like yeah yeah you
know I grew up here and I'm like okay
I'll take the sound like a sample it
will just help me sample yeah oh just
help me I wish I could pick like silent
ubers or something yeah yeah without
pretending to be deaf I don't know I
haven't I don't use uber I use less but
I did hear someone saying like what
there's an option now and then you can
ask for whether or not you want it
silent or I forgot what other options
but they did updates on the matter
yeah could I get in there and then
sometimes I pull out my laptop and I'm
on my phone and my laptop so like
clearly it looks like a worker just to
get their nut no they think I'm working
and it looks like I'm working and then
there's still time or sometimes I can be
on my phone talking to someone and
they're still asking me about what am i
doing like what what kind of job do I
have
yeah I'm like oh my god shut up I know I
mean I don't growing up like i've always
liked talking and like connecting with
people and i've never had a problem with
that but then like the older I've been
getting the more I feel like oh just not
speaking is good it's like it's okay
like it feels good like I have this
friend that whenever we hang out like
sometimes she'll be like okay well you
know what I have I have to recharge
really quick so I'm gonna put in my
headphones really quick listen to music
like if we're driving somewhere and like
our friend like that too
yeah so then so then she'll just really
announce it and say like I need I need
to recharge right now give me my me time
I'm in space and I was like I really
respect that I like that a lot like yeah
let me know what you want and if I ever
feel like I don't want to speak then I
can let you know - like I love that open
communication like there's no need to be
embarrassed I guess so I really like
what this salon is doing I started doing
that with my like in-laws oh I wish I
could go to my in-laws like I used to
feel like I had just sit there
during because there was like they've
like four siblings and they all come
home for Christmas and they all love to
talk and they're so close and I am not
close to my family and so they just I'm
like you know what I don't have to be in
this room like I'm just gonna go
upstairs and like recharge and nobody is
that they're all okay yeah she's Richard
you know it's like it's okay now there
are some people in my family were sold
who are so [ __ ] boring that they they
can't just sit there and be and just
chill right like I'll be on a beach with
them and they're like like oh look at
that purple car and that cool and I'm
like you just shut the [ __ ] up and just
sit here for a sec so I have to leave
I'm not even kidding they uncomfortably
have to like just narrate the
environment that's true don't like move
you up in there at the environment
blocks sounds like what blocks isn't a
blog for sure in the environment oh look
there's a phone on the table in a
rectangular shape but he doesn't know
they're like oh you're not gonna get
judged if you pick the silent treatment
but everyone's gonna be like damn she's
a [ __ ] yeah
if you're a poet this place it sounds
like you know they're they're
non-judgmental if you ask that a regular
life like the friend though I have the
the set I wish I could do that but I
feel like I feel rude
every time even though like I want to do
that and it shouldn't be rude I feel
like my people-pleaser aspect takes over
and it's like no I can't ask it because
it's too much you ever just pretend like
you fell asleep in bed I'll try that I
do have that in the club though like so
I wish that sometimes in the club like
where it's like boom they're like it's
like very over and over repetitive I
wish like I could request like a silent
song like over like a classic can we
just like one song that's like you
should yeah you should go to silent
disco oh yeah she go to those and not
wear the headphones yes and you just
everyone's dancing around you and heavy
ones been it's silent it's really fun
we're just here sleep really fun because
everybody everybody have you want silent
you can but you change it if it if you
like the red channel on and you go oh my
others a really good song on here and
then you change you find someone who has
the red color on and then it's like oh
nineties 90s on this station or like
that sounds so fun I've never even heard
of this
I've heard of silent discos but I
thought it was all like it's all the
same music and it's usually like ravers
that tell me about them so I'm like good
I rolled my eyes truth events are
adopting it so I think it started with
ravers and also it's like if you want a
party but you have a ten o'clock like
noise complaint issue
here you just put you have people put
their headphones do we have like a
people limit because of how many
headphones add like I don't know yeah
yeah I thought it was really stupid now
I think it's really over trumman in
clubs they should that's my problem I
don't want to miss out like I like have
FOMO if I miss out but then like at
justice birthday like when we lost to
West Hollywood and then we were in the
club H I get very overwhelmed like after
a while a bit like same beat I'm like I
need to like I need to just get out for
like five minutes just to I'd left at a
house party just to go sit in the
bathroom to get away from people just
sitting in silence
yeah diarrhea sometimes a sausage
service you should have been a spray
that makes it smell like you just with
diarrhea so they don't know that you're
actually just being rude one time Chuck
Bass from Gossip Girl came into the
bathroom after I did after I pooped
oh girl the guy who lizard acts better
than anyone I've ever seen
yeah dude that guy when he did see he's
like oh so what are you doing later like
all this he's a [ __ ] lizard person
what Chuck Bass dude I know exactly
you're talking about classic classic he
wears purple purple suits and [ __ ] yeah
he smelled my pic he's really
good-looking
did you trying to get him on the show so
I could just make fun of his lizard
photography oh really he's just
naturally that sexy though he could be
cuz there's some dudes that are just I'm
like damn am i gay I was in an elevator
one time with Robert Pattinson
and he was just like chillin with the
ballcap on I was like this guy's [ __ ]
sexy man random guys I only knew because
everyone [ __ ] tensed up in the
elevator when he got in and I was like
okay who the [ __ ] is oh it's Robert
Pattinson
what was sexy about him was he
glistening DS diamond skin okay
rugged no rugged whiskers perfectly
symmetrical whiskers I could only dream
of such things you don't mean like lick
and then he got into like a beat-up red
truck like that's what we all got in the
bar
and I was like this is even sexier he's
just a slice of a [ __ ] American you
know he brought that was during the
height of Twilight so he's probably
doing it just to be incognito though and
now he's gonna be the Batman he'll never
be incognito again oh I served him right
after it was the Kristen Stewart cheated
on him thing and it was his family and
her and they were just like it was the
most tense yeah it was uh it was pretty
nuts
and he was very sexy very ruggedly sexy
very attractive on screen so there must
be something it must be his Cologne if
you're in the same room ISM you wouldn't
have a chance
I barely had a chance hey yeah yeah
[Music]